hello and welcome to big Fink live
I'm Jason gots our guest today is
two-time Tony and Olivier Award winning
actor Jonathan price he's widely known
for his leading roles in the film's
Brazil
Evita the musical Miss Saigon and much
much more
he's currently appearing at the Brooklyn
Academy of Music in a new production of
Harold Pinter's play the caretaker which
is one glowing reviews for its
penetrating new take on the play and for
prices tour de force performance as a
repellant darkly funny and deeply human
Davis Jonathan Pryce welcome to the
program thank you so you've acted in
Hollywood films musicals Shakespeare
television commercials what drew you to
doing this particular production of a
1960 Harold Pinter play now at this
moment in your career and in 2012 well
it started 2009 in in England I was
doing a television show with the
director Christopher Morahan and as we
came to the end of that week he asked me
if I'd ever thought of playing Davis and
the caretaker and I've said it since I'd
played Mick in production for the BBC
and at the National Theatre in London in
1980 I had always thought that one day I
would like to tackle Davis so I said yes
it's something I want to do and if I do
it I want to do it back in Liverpool at
the everyman theatre where I started
work in 1972 40 years ago this year and
we took that idea to the to the everyman
and they welcomed it and that side of it
was something of a sentimental journey
for me and that it was a theatre where I
started
it was the theatre where I was directed
I ran the company for a little while and
they were gonna pull but they have done
now pull the building down and build
new theater so I wanted to do one more
play in there before in the old building
I'd worked there as I said as an actor
but as a teenager I had gone over to
Liverpool to hear bands in the mid 60s I
just missed the Beatles but the cavern
which is where the Beatles started and
the building of the everyman theatre
used to be called Hope Hall and it was a
music venue
when I first so I'd known it you know
practically all my life and it was a
chance to go back there and work yeah I
actually wanted to ask you about that
the you know it seems that you were
revisiting a lot of old haunts in this
production you know doing it with the
everyman
company or in the everyman theatre yeah
and then and then also Davis's Welsh I
know you're from Wales originally you
left young yes I mean well yeah I left
home like will do I did I'd never felt
that I left Wales but it's where I'm
from North Wales yeah sure so I was just
wondering sort of what that experience
you spoke of it as a bit of a
Sentimental Journey what what that
experience was like revisiting all of
those old haunts working maybe with
people that you worked with in the past
yeah no there was nothing knowing nobody
left no it's entirely new new venture
now and it was not going back I was
thinking you know it was I was going to
revisit old old haunts and but I
realized that the life I led when I was
20 when I was there was 25 with the
every month very different to the life I
lead now and although I people were
asking me what what which pubs today is
drinking and what did I used to do in 72
73 and I had to ask my partner Kate who
was or is also an actress who was also
at the every month I said where did I
died had no memories of very
memories of Liverpool at large where did
we used to drink where do we hang out
she said well we're at the theater
all the time because you'd be rehearsing
a show during the day performing at
night and then drinking in the bar
underneath in the the bistro so anyway
that all still exists the drinking yeah
so it does so but none of the people who
had work within the theater and the
starfriend
they don't moved on and okay however it
was what was great going back was that
the the audience hasn't changed it's
that the makeup of the audience is still
very much the same it's still very mixed
audience a mixture of young and old it's
not like many theaters and in
exclusively a middle-class venture which
is what we strive for in the in the 70s
in Liverpool was to bring in a new
audience and the company at the time if
you weren't in the play that was being
performed that week or was for four
weeks five weeks then you were part of
the company called vanload which would
is what it was we loaded up a van and
you took your entertainment to community
centres and pubs and and and tried
ultimately to try and get people to come
into the theater and that that ethos
still exists we met theater do you think
it's limited to that theater have you
encountered it do you feel like there
are places where that sort of ethos
remains alive and well yeah I mean the
people have been forced to do it more
and more and realize it's a very
valuable valuable thing to do because in
a theater outside of London regional
theatre is it used to be it was abundant
in the 70s and there are Brits those
theatres are few and far between and
they're struggling to survive
so they they do go out to to audiences
they work with young people they have
often now they're lovely a Youth Theatre
attached to the theater so it goes on
okay there was a quote in some article
recently and these things get
exaggerated in the news so I don't know
but you know that you had said something
about the the kind of constant Hollywood
sequel ization beings were bad for
culture you know and I just wondered I
wondered whether you had any thoughts on
you know we're talking about theaters
closing down and and there and people
not having access to that outside of
London and New York and the middle class
like whether you have any thoughts on
sort of the importance of the
continuation of yeah like I remember
saying that about blockbusters but
because I've been in a few and I hope to
be in a few more I watch GI Joe too
coming out this summer so I'm not okay
I'm not against the Hollywood
blockbusters I think probably what it
goes in cycles and waves in that the
blockbusters will take over and you know
they'll be filling the cinemas all
summer and then somebody will make an
independent film that to everyone's
surprise will make money and so the
studios and independent producers will
say that that's that's the way to go now
so they'll start putting money into
smaller independent productions until
they realize oh well then I'm making any
money anymore and what what the mistake
is I think is that the they don't
realize it's it's the product that makes
the successful film it's the script it's
the cast it's that film it's not that
independence a very simplistic way of
putting it is not that independent
cinema is is by its nature successful
and what people want to see all the time
cinema will it's been in the doldrums of
economically you know the past two or
three years but it is now beginning to
pick up again and I hope it is I'm being
reassured it is thing
so things are happening and it's it all
depends if the films are good if they
you know if if this particular Marvel
comic is made into a good film it'll
sell if it's crap it's it's crap and
nobody's gonna go and see it so Wow but
theater itself it is it depends where
you go the West End of London is this
year is thriving since we had our
economic crash people went more to the
theatre the box office figures went up I
think it was partly to do with people
staying when I say staying at home I
mean not taking their holidays abroad
staying in the country being entertained
you know they want to go out and be
entertained regional theatre is it's a
struggle and many of the theaters that
young actors when the left drama school
went naturally went to to work when they
left drama school in the 70s and early
80s
they don't exist those opportunities
don't exist funding was withdrawn from
the arts huge sums were cut initially
under the Thatcher government a woman
who had no love of theatre and a love of
culture as far as I could see and they
suppressed any a lot of the successful
theatre in Britain was left-wing fit and
it so they managed to cut off the
funding for a lot of left-wing socialist
theaters or anything that was trying to
tell the truth about society so I want
to I want to come back to the play that
you're in now Harold Pinter is the
caretaker and
to ask you a bit about the journey of
your character
Davis toward the end in particular the
emotional rollercoaster was very strong
strongly reminding me of King Lear and
and I just I just wonder if you could
talk a bit about the character and sort
of what what the journey is that he is
well the unfortunate thing is my next
job is I'm playing King Lear and I think
I might have spent top of my head Cheon
Davis
and I've said to people that my layer
it'll be the same performance with
different words you know and there may
be a lot of truth in that I know and
also Davis has been in this production
has been referred to by critics as a you
know a kitchen sink layer or you know
all that stuff but he's on a similar
emotional journey and but and it depends
how you as an actor how you want to
interpret it when when I played Mick in
1980 the actor who was playing Davis did
it nothing
well very little crossover what he did
and what I'm doing and I think I'm
responding this is in Rachel's but
retrospect is when I'm when I was
rehearsing it and thinking about it I
didn't think like this I'm nervous like
being a bit objective about it because
people are asking me to talk about it I
don't normally like talking about it but
I think it it's a reflection of the
times in that homelessness and mental
illness there was a kind of romantic
view of the Tramp the hobo that Davis
was in the late 50s
someone who that I used to see when I
was growing up from Wales a tramp was
someone who'd be literally tramping the
highways walking for miles and miles and
M from town to town and you know a
gentleman of the road they were called
and all that stuff but now homelessness
is
it's a much more brutal life it's it's
much more urban there you know they you
don't see people camping the roads going
from town to town they they're focused
on a place where they can get support
and help and it's it's much more huh
it's much harder for that for the
homeless person now than it ever was in
their late 50s and 60s and even when in
the 80s when I did it when I say played
Mick and the issue of mental illness is
now also much more linked to
homelessness because again my favorite
government the Thatcher government and
was your Reagan government introduced
policies where institutions for the
mentally ill were closed down and people
were they they had the phrase for it and
in Britt which was care in the community
where people were they were just let out
of hospital in in and supposed to be
absorbed into society and get help in
smaller institutions and they did and it
did it worked to a certain extent and
people work very hard and well for in
order to help the mentally ill but it
just means there are more and more
people on the streets who need help and
that image that you take it into the
caretaker
it makes Davis's journey that he's much
he's much more angry than he ever would
have been I do play him because the
nature of the piece is that you can and
nature of drama a lot of the times you
sought from people up with comedy and
the funnier it is when the the darker
side comes in then it amplifies the dark
side of the play that's the hope anyway
and I think the the journey that Davis
goes on in in manipulating the two
brothers to I mean he yes he wants
somewhere to
but I think more than that he wants
there's a corny way of looking pretty
once love and Christopher Morin
director says that for him it's a play
about love and burn that love for the
two brothers Davis is desperate for you
know a relationship with someone anyone
and and so at the end it's the end of
the piece which I mean Christopher has
made quite enigmatic with this sort of
final tableau image but it is for Davis
incredibly desperate and there was three
lions he has is with what am I going to
do what shall I do
where am I gonna go is the the cry of
you know millions of people around the
world so it's it it becomes a very
universal issue at that point it's
interesting to hear it expressed as as
love that he's after because watching it
you know for me as an audience member it
was um what struck me was that he was
looking for an anchor of legitimacy or
someone to sort of take his side in a
sense perhaps is the same thing yeah as
love yeah it's I think it is yeah
someone to stand up for you yeah so um I
wanted to ask you know there's there's
sort of old truisms in in the American
theater about the differences between
the British and American styles of
acting which I think are a bit
exaggerated perhaps but I noticed in
watching your performance how really
seamlessly you blend you know you you
you you do a lot of detail work in terms
of the body of the character your hands
are shaking you you know the and and
you're not forgetting to do these things
as you're as you're going through the
role and it's animated at the same time
by a very real soul whereas we sometimes
separate actors
out in American actors out into sort of
character actors on the one hand who are
good at physical detail work and
changing their voices and and then I
don't know maybe another breed of actors
who sort of play themselves do you have
any thoughts on those differences are
they totally illusory or I I think they
it it Oh comes it comes down to the
individual I don't think there's a I
think if I tended to notice it more when
I first started to work here in the
seventies there was a difference because
I think I my exposure in in the theatre
was such that it was what I did was very
varied I was doing a different play
every five or six weeks a different
character I came from that theatre was a
it gave me huge confidence and a
fearlessness to tackle any kind of role
and occasionally with American actors I
worked with hadn't had that broad outlet
for their work and they generally worked
with a teacher worked on their own roles
and their own characterizations in often
in isolation to the rest of the cast and
they were it was about presenting your
work rather than a shared experience
with your other actors and I'd come very
much from the shared experience and I'm
not that's not exclusively British or
American but it's that was something
that I was aware of and I'm still aware
of today especially when you make a film
where it tends to have more of the
American actors that is that they will
have a coach who will work on their
scenes and work on their characters and
they come to work and whatever anybody
says says to them they're going to do
their work they're going to present
their character in the way they worked
on at home and it's a bit like you know
if you practice things in front of a
mirror and it's it becomes about the you
rather than a story you're telling
or how you relate to the euro director
interesting it's not everybody please
America I'm not condemning but and I
think it makes her very ultimately yeah
I suppose what people are doing that
they're trying to survive in a business
film business where it's not necessarily
about how you relate to the other actors
but how you relate to the camera and
providing the director with enough
material that they can build a
performance and build a story but I
still see it as to me it's it's still
like a theater process I'd like to I
don't like talking to a piece of tape on
the side of a camera I'd rather talk to
the human being and yeah there you go
okay fashion but the last thing I wanted
to ask you is just about why what your
thoughts are on if you have any on this
on why talented versatile British actors
are so often cast as the bad guy in
Hollywood movies you know you you
terrified my twelve-year-old self as mr.
dark and something wicked this way comes
you're scaring a new generation of
children in the Pirates of the Caribbean
one of my you know one of my favorite
actors Gary Oldman is frequently cast as
the bad guy in American movies as well
any thoughts on that is that simply
because the bad guy is hard to play or
and so you need something so the bad guy
is often the easiest easy a role to play
because they're often though they
best-written because the the
screenwriter can have fun and indulge
and the the good guys react most of the
time to that but I am
I still I don't know I why I don't know
why I am playing the American president
in GI Joe - I don't know why I know why
I don't know why but I I play both guy I
play the good president and bad
presidents and I I have scenes with
myself which are interesting to do and I
found the other actor I was working with
at that time very very proficient knew
his lines but I honestly don't know it's
become a kind of historical fact now
that British actors play on the whole
play at the bad guys I mean and yeah I
don't know why it started I think
because the you know the we were the bad
guys were the Germans and so they needed
you know we English people British
people could put on a German accent
there's World War two films play the bad
guys and we could do Russian accents and
all that stuff
we ate we're aliens I think hmm I think
we're all foreigners to Americans thank
you so much for being with us today
Jonathan Pryce and we invite our big
Fink audience to visit
www.opm.gov/health Pinter's the
caretaker that play is running through
June 17th and please check back - big
thing calm to watch additional video
clips from our conversation with
jonathan pryce and to find out about
future live interviews with our experts
thanks for watching and thanks again
Jonathan for being with my pleasure
thank you
you